welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
box and rick and morty season five is
coming way sooner than we thought
maybe even by the end of 2020 with a new
season five episode cold open revealed
by dan harmon over this past comic-con
weekend i'm gonna break down all the
easter eggs that you might have missed
from the cinematic because there were a
ton of them on each of those shards
and then i'm going to go and do all the
key takeaways from the panel
spoiler warning in case i accidentally
predict anything too well in room in
your life all right let's start with the
clip
come on rick we're almost there leave me
morty
it's the only way what were we
are we blades in that one that's tight
stay with me
i'm i'm scared morty i can see the end
oh god there's nothing i know i always
said that but
oh god there's really nothing okay uh
real quick here morty and rick are
fleeing a battle with some
interdimensional lovecraftian beast
similar to the abilis from guardians vol
2 i guess
it's feasting on all these blue crystals
depicting
alternate realities actually at first i
was thinking these could be the four
bojolon death crystals from the season
four premiere ones that showed all the
possible fates
but in most of these here they don't
really look like they're dying the one
rick notices shows he and morty in a
wesley snipes blade reality
with morty bearing blade's appearance
and killing vampires in a dance club but
right away at the top
you can see rick as a pope or a bishop
he's sticking a finger in morty's mouth
gross another one shows rick and morty
as birds fighting over a worm there's
one where their heads are conjoined
another where they have block heads and
one morty and rick hug each other in
terror and that one
collides with one of morty cradling baby
rick with a burpee towel over his
shoulder
this could be a callback to season three
episode vii the return of the citadel
mr morty mr morty i cloned myself so you
could kiss me as a baby one depicts rick
is a lumberjack
chopping down morty trees and then
there's like a veiny disease rick
smashing into a cool sunglasses morty
now most of these crystals are also tear
drop shaped like i'm wondering if they
represent painful or tearful moments
from other dimensions
and this could be why rick who's near
death panics upon realizing that there's
nothing on the other side
all possibilities are collapsing around
him and he realizes that they all just
lead to a void
and so morty pilots them out of this
shrinking window back to earth but you
can see how that closing portal
clips part of the ship forcing a crash
landing and morty uses what he thinks
are his dying moments to call jessica
morty bounces the ship off a palm tree
and lands in the water
so we learn a new rule about rick he
cannot ever touch earth's ocean water
because of some treaty with a society of
ocean dwellers led by his nemesis mr
nimbus it looks like he's inspired by
superheroes like namor the submariner he
emerges from a giant clam shell like
botticelli's
birth of venus and nimbus looks like
just as much of a thirst trap
i am assuming that this is connected to
that unseen ricklantis mix-up plot
yeah atlantis baby that was amazing you
got some of that mermaid push i'm really
hoping it wasn't a one-off thing and i
could see her again
now morty was there for that adventure
so he should know
nimbuses if it is connected but maybe
back in season three rick took morty on
a quick sneaky mermaid sexcapade without
telling morty about the
broader ocean treaty with nimbus that
they were violating like even if it's
just a callback joke to those mermaids i
would love if this season five nimbus
episode ties in the events of that
season three episodes since i always
wanted to see what that adventure was
and not just because i have a thing for
a mermaid i mean it's like a finn so
where's the uh where's the you know
is it gill we should move on to the big
reveals that harmon made about season
five and season six but hey before we
continue thanks to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
every cannabing is 16 ounces it contains
300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has
zero calories yet it tastes so good
there's over 20 different flavors to
choose from this flavor is pina colada
we're in those
warmer summer months now you might want
a fruity drink but you know not
go anywhere that serves fruity drinks i
get it that great tiki party can happen
in your mouth
with a can of bang and it gives you so
much energy so you can just
do the limbo by yourself check out bang
on instagram you can get 25
off your order at bangdashenergy.com
when you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their keto coffee flavor their
sweet tea flavor
you can also get clothing fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang dashenergy.com using the
code newrockstars25
okay on to the big reveals from the
panel harman confirmed that the writers
working remotely under quarantine has
actually made seasons five and six some
of the most productive for the series
that they're ahead of schedule for once
and they're finessing the finale of
season five currently with writers
working on their drafts for season six
episodes this is
a huge deal folks because it means that
we might see rick and morty season five
episodes by the end of this year
if not early 2021 which given the gap
between seasons three and four
is way sooner than i think any of us
expected harmon confirmed that the clone
beth mystery would not be explored
deeper in season five but that there
would be quote
clone beth fireworks in season six and
he confirmed that the writers never
intended it to be determinable one way
or the other
which beth was rick's original beth and
which was the clone and that rick just
wiped his memories
that he would never know rick uh also
upon finding out that
he that he also made himself forget that
he doesn't know and when he found out he
doesn't know he
said i'm a terrible father which is a
metaphor for us saying we're bad writers
um
but it's also like a very ancient greek
thing where it's like zeus
is atoning with athena and going like i
don't this is how i create i create
through abuse
it's interesting that harm incites greek
mythology as an inspiration for rick's
paternal guilt
because the episode that preceded the
clone beth finale was rick's battle with
the greek god
zeus the epic fist fight between two
dads in the bleachers
zeus is known for conceiving countless
children with mortal women by taking
various forms
created all kinds of problems and later
on he confesses his guilt over this to
the goddess of wisdom and war athena
who definitely seems to be an
inspiration for beth's character in rick
and morty and then harmon went on about
rick's daddy shane
i have created now two women who are
have been bifurcated by
my aggressive refusal to um
commit to anything and if if that's not
where the buck stops and
if i don't now accept this then what
happens are there
is there an infinite beth you know
storyline that happens
harman stop yes there is
you've heard it here first infinite
that's it
well it could just be a bit by harmon or
we could have just seen him in real time
conceive a season six plot line about
infinite cloned bets representing a
spectrum of rick's toxic qualities it
was also interesting to see in this
animatic clip morty take his final phone
call because during the panel
harmon mentioned his one great regret
from season 4 was that he never better
fleshed out
jerry's near death and his final phone
call when he was floating up into the
sky in that rattlestar galactica episode
hi honey uh look morty told me that you
didn't think i could hang lights without
killing myself
look i want to be a strong man for you
but the truth is the truth is
i'm coming home with the best lights
ever at a certain point in that story
again
just to pinch it off and resolve it
jerry behaves very
brightery uh he's i mean
internal logic starts to rattle he's
grabbing an airplane in it
with a with a couple more months i could
have made that episode great
there was actually a similar moment with
rick in the season two premiere
i'm okay with this be good morty be
better than me
the other caller i'm not okay with this
i am not okay with this
oh sweet jesus please let me live oh my
god i got that i gotta fix this thing
please got it heaven please god oh lord
hear my prayers
yes you god not today [ __ ]
and now harmon and the writers appear to
be redeeming these past near-death
moments short changed with laughs by
having morty explore his
real last moment alive relationship with
jessica harmon revealed in the panel
that the vindicators would not be coming
back in season five but
might take another form in season six is
another vindicator
story possible uh it hasn't yet but we
got
actually there's some uh treats coming
your way in an ancillary
sense and harman made it clear that the
writers did not have any big answer for
what the cat voiced by matthew broderick
did
that made jerry and rick so grossed out
but he was asked to drop a cryptic tease
for season five that wouldn't make sense
until we saw it in the season could you
give us like a
super cryptic tease that will only make
sense
once we actually see season five to
kind of wet everyone's appetites jerry
i will not do that and there's no
character on earth that could ever make
me do it
what about me it could be just another
joke
but months before season four harmon did
make a similar joke about clone beth
that absolutely
ended up being true when season 4 came
out so what do you think he means by
this
comment down below and join the deeper
discussion on our official discord
server by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars follow me on
instagram at
avos i got some fun rick and morty fan
art on that and we'll do episode
breakdowns and we explained after shows
when season 5 arrives so subscribe to
new rockstars
stay up to date with all of it thank you
for watching stay safe and [ __ ] death
[Music]
you